okay in this lesson we're going to talk
about the greatest common factors how to
find it and how to
solve problems involve you know finding
the greatest common factor so let's get
right into it let's talk about you know
what's the greatest common factor
between 18 and 30. now when we talk
about the greatest common factor what
we're talking about is what's the
greatest or the largest number that will
divide in evenly into 18 and into 30
okay so the largest number that goes
into divides into evenly and so one way
to do this is to do a prime
factorization tree so if i break this
number down into its prime factors you
can see this is 2 to the first times 3
to the second whereas with 30 that's 6
times 5
2 times 3 so this is 2 to the first
times three to the first times five to
the first okay
and when you find the greatest common
factor what you do is you compare these
factors you take the
quantity that occurs the least so what i
mean by that is you have one two one two
you take which occurs the least number
of times it's a tie we're just gonna
take one two here we have two threes one
three we take the one that occurs the
least and then here we have no fives one
five we take the one that occurs the
least which is no fives two times three
is six that's the greatest common factor
that's the largest number that will go
into 18 and 30 evenly so you use the
greatest common factor when you're
reducing fractions like say you're
reducing 18 divided by 30. if you divide
these both by 6 that's going to be 3
fifths and you're able to reduce it in
one step by dividing these both by the
greatest common factor
so when you do this if you use the prime
factorization method
even though it's the greatest common
factor you want to pick the quantity
okay that
occurs the least so it's actually the
opposite right okay so we're going to do
this problem go ahead and pause the
video see if you can solve this it says
if a and b are positive integers such
that the greatest common factor of a
cubed b
and a squared b cubed is 20
which could a equal is it 5 2 10 or 20.
so see if you can solve this one pause
the video and we'll do it together
okay so what we're going to do here is
we're going to just break down a q to b
now a cubed b is just already basically
in prime factored form right and over
here we have a squared b cubed so if
we're taking the greatest common factor
this one has three a's this one has two
a's we're going to take the one that
occurs
least right the lowest
b to the first b cubed we take the one
that occurs least that's just one b so
our greatest common factor here is going
to be a squared times b right
now when we look at 20 if we do the
prime factorization on 20 that's 4 times
5 and 4 is 2 times 2. so if you write
this in prime
and you know in the factored form here 2
squared
times 5 to the first you can see that
this looks a lot like a squared times b
right so it looks like b would be 5
right because there's one of them it
looks like a would be 2 because there's
2 of them so it says
which could a equal it looks like a is
going to be 2 and the best answer here
is letter b
so that's how you would solve these
problems you want to first break down
the number okay and then you can find
out what the greatest common factor is
by picking which occurs the least okay
and then you can compare these two to
one another so this was a kind of a
typical problem that showed up on a
previous ect test so review this again
if you need to and i'll see you in the
next lesson